(upbeat music)
(ambulance siren)
(bottle sprays)
(gasps)
- Where am I?
What's going on?
- Oh you just woke up from
a long coma, sweetheart.
You're in the hospital.
- Okay, can you get my doctor?
- Oh wow, just
because I'm a woman,
I can't be your doctor?
Women are a lot of things now
sweetie, thank you very much.
- Yeah no, I'm sorry.
I was just surprised that--
- The Ghostbusters!
They're women now.
Did you know that?
- I think I heard that actually.
- And the movie was awful!
Women can suck now too.
- Okay, women can suck now.
- They're also doing
all female reboots
of Oceans Eleven, 21 Jump
Street, and What About Bob.
(gasps) Does that
intimidate you?
- No, actually that
sounds really fun, I would--
- Did you know the Wachowski
Brothers are women now?
Yeah, that's right honey.
Women can be brothers now too!
- Well I don't think that
technically they can.
- Oh we can, baby, and we do.
Put that in your penis
pipe and smoke it!
- Okay, I'm sorry.
I think we got off
on the wrong foot.
- Women have feet now too!
- Okay.
- Look, there's
another female doctor.
We're everywhere, bitch.
- Hey, I'm a man!
Men can have long hair now too!
- Oh that one's on me, my bad.
(grunt)
(crash)
- Okay.
I'm sorry, I get it.
Women can do anything
a man can do.
- Thank you.
- So there must be a female
president by now, huh?
- Oh hell, you
didn't just go there!
You know what, women can
smother your ass too now!
(upbeat music)
Get you back in that
motherfuckin' coma!